uns haben breaking news erreicht die
demonstranten in berlin versuchen jetzt
das reichstagsgebäude zu stürmen wollen
auch gleich mal hier die aktuellen
bilder vor dem reichstag in berlin
zeigen
die polizei hat sich dort aufgestellt
wütende demonstranten versuchten das
gebäude zu stürmen die lage ist äußerst
angespannt wir sehen hier die beamten
wie sie sich aufgestellt haben auf der
anderen seite sehen wir die
demonstranten die ja die beamten
beschimpfen und versuchen das
reichstagsgebäude zu stürmen wir sind
für sie vor ort mein kollege peter wilke
ist vor dem berliner reichstag täter wir
sehen jetzt diese situation gerade sie
ist äußerst angespannt der tag hat uns
immer wieder über kochen szenen
beschreibt täter wie ist die situation
vor dem reichstag radios am reichstag
angekommen was erstmal sagen kann hier
ist eine enorme polizei also wirklich
durch die polizei haben mit dem ganzen
tag über noch nicht auf einem pfund
zusammen sehen wir konnten das
beobachten die wand wo er noch unter den
linden und auf einmal sind alle
polizisten in ihre autos gesprungen und
hier in richtung reichstag gefahren
auch das tor noch sehr sehr viele
polizisten polizeiwagen mannschaftswagen
der polizei
ja und was sie über twitter auch videos
gesehen haben anscheinend sind
demonstranten in den sicherheitsbereich
des reichstags davon sind gitterzäune
normalerweise leute durch eine
sicherheitskontrolle geben vorerst vor
die tür vor dem weiterkommen
und anscheinend sind sie dort in den
sicherheitsbereich eingedrungen ich weiß
gar nicht ob er noch drauf sind und auf
jeden fall ist die polizei sofort
hierhin gestürmt um den ganzen bereich
zu sichern die demonstranten wechsel
klinge sieht so aus als wenn sie das
jetzt auch geschafft haben sehr viele
polizeikräfte stehen vor dem reichstag
und sperren dort alles ab haben
demonstranten zurückgedrängt und ja auch
gegen uns gegenüber auch gegenüber
presse normalerweise kann man geht es
einem presseausweis noch mehr rankommen
es bestehen aber dabei absolut keine
ausnahme da wurde jeder zurückgedrängt
hier wurde jetzt erstmal alles komplett
abgesperrt komplett ist gemacht
wie schätzt du peter die lage derzeit
vor ort ein es ist ja eigentlich gerade
eine großkundgebung am laufen am großen
stern dorthin haben sich die
demonstranten die gegen die korona
regeln sind bis zu 38.000 demonstranten
haben sich heute in berlin
zusammengefunden und dorthin haben sind
sie eigentlich jetzt gewandert jetzt ist
es so dass wieder vor dem reichstag sich
eine menschenmenge zusammen gefunden hat
wie offenbar versucht hat das
reichstagsgebäude zu stürmen du konntest
du sagen es würde der sicherheitsbereich
sogar erreicht wie schätzt du die lage
jetzt ein wie es dort weitergeht aktuell
sieht es einfach danach aus als wenn die
gesamten polizeikräfte zusammengezogen
werden um das einfach zu sichern
sie kann auch nach da schauen dass
stehen die polizisten sehr viele
demonstranten kommen aus dem tiergarten
und wollen wohl wieder hierhin und weist
nach dem begraben da für leute
eingedrungen sind
es kann auch der berichten als wir an
auch unter den linden bahn und da sie
sich den botschaft verbreitet hat dass
leute in den bereisten gleich tags
eingedrungen sind inter die
sicherheitskontrollen das wurde da
teilweise sogar gefahr hat ja jetzt für
hier meinte jemand schafft neu eine
revolution also die jetzt teilweise
freude darüber dass man das jetzt hier
passiert ist die demonstranten stehen
ebenso hinter den säulen konnten
zurückgedrängt werden und die polizei
sichert hier jetzt größtenteils alles ab
und macht erstmal komplett bistum einen
überblick über die lage zu bekommen
herr peter uns haben auch bilder
erreicht die wir uns jetzt einmal
ansehen wollen die sind circa zehn
minuten alt da hat genau das
stattgefunden hat schon jetzt berichten
konnte sehen wie hier die dem
entspannten die sicherheitszäune
überspringen und teilweise umwerfen und
so gelingt es ihnen dann auch in den
sicherheitsbereich des reichstag
vorzudringen
hier sehen wir diese bilder etwa zehn
minuten alt wir sehen wie die polizei
hinterher eilt und versuchte dieser
situation herr zu werden
der reichstag ist breit weiträumig
abgesperrt es kam dort im laufe des
tages bereits zu sehr schwierigen
situationen immer wieder musste die
polizei dort eingreifen hier sehen wir
jetzt die bilder zehn minuten in etwa
sind sie als demonstranten versuchten
das reichstagsgebäude für stürmen und
ihnen ist es auch gelungen in den
sicherheitsbereich des reichstags
einzudringen
im moment ist die lage vor ort sehr sehr
angespannt polizei und demonstranten
stehen sich gegenüber heute sind bis zu
38.000 menschen laut dem berliner
innensenator auf den straßen wir sehen
hier aber auch menschen friedlich sitzen
gerade live oder anderen ecke sehen wir
die bilder live vor dem
reichstagsgebäude
auf der anderen seite sehen wir die
bilder jetzt auch wieder mein kollege
peter wilke vor ort peter du bist jetzt
dort vor dem reichstagsgebäude wir haben
es eben gerade gesagt
dort ist es demonstranten gelungen in
einen sicherheitsbereich vorzudringen
wie beherrscht die polizei im moment die
lage kannst du uns einen überblick geben
wird wie viel beamten sie dort vor ort
sind und wie sich die lage im moment
überhaupt gestaltet sie ist sehr
schwierig zu überblicken scheint er kann
sagen ich sei beherrscht die lage erst
mal mit enorm sind
wir können noch einmal hier in den
staaten hinunterschauen
zum ende der straße ist bis zum ende der
straße hier und auch auf der anderen
seite nur polizei den wagen nur
mannschaft muss sich vorstellen in ein
so mancher fan fassen
mehrere polizisten mehrere polizeibeamte
seien über 500 seiten können das
teilweise platin also das kann so ein
beeindruckend wie viel polizeipräsenz
gar nicht hier vor ort ist da hinten
denn wir sehen die polizisten drängen
ähnlich demonstranten geht auch darüber
gelegt und dann fängt außerdem werden
italien zurück und ja jetzt geht es
erstmal darum mit enormen menschen
wieder hier wegzufliegen vom reichstag
in alle richtungen erst mal klar zu
schaffen freiraum schaffen hier soll
jetzt keiner mehr ist mal sein